ce que j'estime comme un des plus grands
acquis de la révolution et des acquis
qu'on a eue après le 14 janvier c'est la
liberté d'expression c'est que
aujourd'hui dans la tunisie
d'aujourd'hui les gens ils peuvent
s'exprimer et par exemple sur internet
les gens ils sont plus obligés de cacher
leur identité ou leur adresse ip ou de
de se cacher derrière des faux profils
pour exprimer leurs opinions et des
idées et et avis est aussi même dans la
vraie vie et dans les cafés dans les
parties dans les clubs dans les dents
les débats etc et surtout principalement
dans les médias c'est aujourd'hui les
gens ils peuvent s'exprimer et dire ce
qu'ils veulent et exposer leurs idées de
la manière qu'ils veulent sans pour
autant risquer leur vie ou risquer la
prison
donc ça j'estime que c'est un une
excellente base sur laquelle on peut
construire beaucoup et notamment faire
énormément de changements